this is cladney's plate
chadni or cladney is spelt
c-h-l-a-d-n-i and i think it's cladney
well if i put a violin bow down here i
can get it to resonate at frequencies
but we haven't got a violin bow so i'm
going to tune it to 450 hertz where this
thing has a resonance and you'll be able
to hear it singing away quite nicely to
you
and as i change the resonant i'll go
through the resonance there and you get
this sound coming out this the middle of
the plate is being shaken up and down
and it's held fixed there but the plate
is going to bow out and there are going
to be places which i can't show you yet
where it's going to be stationary in
other parts which will be oscillating up
and down like mad in order to visualize
it what we're going to do is put some
carborundum powder which is
a little material which is about 0.3
millimeters in diameter and sprinkle it
on the surface so i just do that gently
and you can see that i'm spraying it all
over the whole surface
and then
we turn up
the amplitude of oscillation
and you can see
into this lovely pattern well we've got
lines where the grains of carborundum
have gone where the displacement of the
metal
is zero so it's shaking up and down but
this place it doesn't move at all this
is called the nodal line this is the
place where nothing is displaced no
displacement means nodes and
in the middle you get another node and
then around the outside you get these
beautiful lines symmetric for this
rectangular shape showing you these
nodal lines uh that's the place
where they like to be thrown so it's
being thrown up and down and if they end
up there they're not going to be moved
at all and so that's the place where
they end up without wanting to move i
can also run this experiment again at a
different frequency i if i turn this up
to about 690 hertz
this plate
and you're getting these curved lines
coming out right there george
in this case you've got another pattern
like that with lines at the edge
okay so we've
we've ended up with a particular pattern
now i'm going to throw a spanner in the
works by showing you what happens if i
use very fine powders this is much
smaller diameter this is lycopodium
powder which is
very very small and i'll sprinkle a bit
on
oh that's probably too much
over the top and then we'll see what
happens to that
and having done that you can see i've
got more particles in the middle i've
still got this pattern on the outside
with a heavier grey particle but inside
you have a yellow pattern a square
pattern which is lying between this line
on the outside and the gray area in the
middle equidistance and this is the area
where the displacement of the plate is
the greatest in english this plate is
flapping up and down and where the
amplitude of the flapping motion up and
down is the greatest that's where these
particles end up and the reason for that
is due to the effect of this flapping up
and down motion on the air scaling this
up to the let's take this as a large
particle and it's jiggling about on the
surface and it finds itself at the place
where there is no jiggly motion of the
surface up and down and it just stays
there this represents a smaller particle
and i have a little bed of them and as
this is thrown up
there's a partial vacuum in the air
underneath this bed of particles and the
air rushes in from the sides to fill
that vacuum nature bores a vacuum so you
find that there is a flow of air
underneath these particles which gathers
them all together in the same space
the big particles decided to sit it out
on the sidelines like
those those people who go around
dances and sit on the sidelines what do
you call them men
yes probably drinking their beer and and
they stay there and don't get involved
in the activities whereas these women
all jump up and down
and then underneath and they're all
sucked into one area only that's
happening here look at it they've made
little piles and as these piles rise up
air goes underneath them and instead of
spreading out the air drags them back
into a little pile this was an effect
discovered by faraday in 1830 1831 yes
1831 180 odd years
ago
and this is called faraday piling let me
read from his paper
the beautiful series of forms issued by
sand filings or other grains when lying
upon vibrating plates discovered and
developed by cladney are so striking as
to recall to the minds of those who have
seen them by the slightest reference
they indicate the quiescent parts
of those plates and visibly figure out
what are called nodal lines
you